2 million cent mille spectateurs c'est
notre chiffre du jour
il s'agit du nombre de personnes qui se
sont rendues au cinéma depuis une
semaine dans tout l'hexagone une très
bonne reprise pour les professionnels du
secteur et ce malgré une jauge fixé à 35
%
même constat du côté des terrasses des
bars restaurants qui ont été prises
d'assaut malgré un temps maussade
une semaine jour pour jour après le
lancement de la phase 2 du déconfinement
on fait le bilan avec samuel colin ce
mercredi au cinéma des deux lions les
séances de 15 heures font le plein c'est
vrai qu'un petit cinéma ça fait du bien
de temps en temps surtout avec les amis
avant la fin d'année
ça fait du bien de voir ressortir et
refaire des choses qu'on avait
l'habitude de faire avant vos coeurs
c'est top
à nouveau lors des sorties en famille
donc entre amis ou à 2 e et ça fait du
bien fondé de prendre l'air d'avoir du
monde c'est plutôt sympa ça permet de
passer cet après-midi même s'il faut
respecter distanciation
les treize salles du complexe ont
régulièrement atteint leur jauge et des
du mauvais temps ces derniers jours et
par les deux succès du box office en ce
moment le manga damon slayer et le film
adieu les cons on est ravi de retrouver
nos clients et les résultats sont très
encourageants puisque on a des chiffres
qui sont qui sont très bons on a rempli
cette jauge de 35% assez fréquemment
de l'autre côté de la ville même si
elles gris et même sourire radieux
ça fait plaisir de voir voilà les
terrasses ouvertes un peu de vie on voit
des sourires sur les visages des
personnes
une semaine après sa réouverture le
restaurant renouvelle deux fois sa
clientèle en terrasse au déjeuner 140
couverts chaque midi
l'équivalent d'un bon service malgré la
jauge de 35% une clientèle d'entreprises
et d'habitués on a eu énormément
énormément de monde les gens voulaient
absolument profiter de nos terrasses et
revivre normalement quelque part ça
réchauffe le coeur de voir que nos
entreprises repartent les services
commencent une heure avant midi et soir
des soirées plus calme dû notamment au
couvre-feu de 21h30 une étape le 9 juin
avec l'ouverture de l'intérieur des
restaurants pour les cinémas la jauge
passera alors à 65%